you guys have missed it because we had a
lot of off record off air conversation
about the horrors of stand-up Michael
McDonald the great Michael McDonald
MADtv alum and now director producer
writer millionaire millionaire yeah
thank you for keeping it only as a
single-digit millionaire that's right
and and with piercing blue eyes I don't
know if you seen Michael in person but
he's got piercing blue eyes I you know I
didn't tell you that you're gonna be
co-hosting no you didn't know and so
that's what you're doing you're
co-hosting the fighter and the kid I
mostly thought I just I knew I just be
doing a lot of listening well well I
haven't let you talk a lot but I will
say that you are the celebrity or you
know certainly to MADtv alum I'm I'm
confused for the most really uh-huh so
if one more person says I loved you a
steward on MADtv and I and by the way I
have never denied it I've always said
thank you
that happens to me with Will Ferrell and
I always accept it and I'm not joking
I really I think I do the cheerleader
one time
in the middle of my stand-up show in
West Palm Beach Florida sir 45 minutes
into the show
I'm actually like rap practically
wrapping the show up and I talk about
you know who I am in my own stand-up
show and there was a little lull in the
conversation and that's when people like
to yell out or whatever and a girl said
do the cheerleaders and I couldn't
believe it
in my own stand-up show 45 minutes in I
would have done I Know Who I just would
have died I almost broke down to tears
well you're kind of glad not to be doing
stand-up yeah everybody's glad not to be
doing it well when they I mean nobody
really loves it I know that he has say
they're looking well I think what you're
talking about is I did the performance
is great but the travel the sort of the
role of managers you know we're like hey
I'm not trying to nickel and dime you
but isn't how about you stay in this
hostile
well one time I was in Tennessee and I
was doing a club and I get into my condo
and I'm kind of unpacking and I I know
it just looked around and yep and I yep
and I a guy walks out of the other room
and I go I'm grown man am i sharing this
with you sir Oh was was that ever sack
when I was young enough so I did not
even young enough but I just I'm not a
diva I don't care enough I I'm not going
to make a scene I should be you I would
imagine wouldn't be having it and I
wouldn't have that but I would I
wouldn't I wouldn't throw a fit and like
not do a show I would just quietly go
get a hotel room and I wouldn't it
wouldn't even matter to me it had cost
me like I wouldn't care because that to
me is the ultimate I have to have a nice
hotel or nice place to at least burrow
into - while I cry and drink over the
life that I'm living well let me ask you
this for me when I'm on the road so when
I'm doing a long weekend right if I'm
doing like some Thursday to Saturday
Thursday that it used to be Thursday
Sunday Oulu tomorrow oh no I used to I
can't
the key to me was quickly as quickly as
I could just do Friday Saturday that's
it yes now here's the thing I would do I
get in Wednesday I would leave on Monday
oh okay I used to do that now the
problem with that is that look for
anybody out there as a job they hate
when we're complaining about being
comics like hear me out you people in
the Middle East I know you think you've
got a bet
I know you Syrian refugee and think it's
bad so so this is all in context but
this is what I mean to say the amount of
time that you spend alone means your
hotel room and then walking and then you
eat but you're not really talking to
anybody
so you're very isolated all day and then
you go and do this you have this
experience where again you're alone on
stage you're getting tremendous
interesting yep and then you go from
there to isolate you take the mixers I
guess so yeah well don't buy your DVDs
right they and again we were talking
about I used to sell merch where I stand
out behind a table I did it up
approximately three times because I just
I couldn't
you're like a circus freak in a cage
shares 20 bucks if you buy the CD
thirty-five I can't I Oh how much more
do I make two grand 3 grand 10 grand I
don't care because it was not were they
more depressed right yeah then what
happens is you get married so usually I
was younger I at least try to find a
girl that I could spend like a night get
laid I was so depressed that I had to
just I just wanted that human Konrad
right anyway the point is that then you
get married and that becomes more
complicated because you know your wife
will get mad if you're cheating on it so
so there's all kinds of issues like that
so you really do spend so much of your
time alone right mm-hmm or and the other
thing is if you have just like a low
level of being known as I would say I
have a very very low level but just
enough yes that people feel comfortable
to when if you do go out during the day
yeah uh to have to take pictures while
you're eating when you're eating on and
I hop in many ways that guy and then
that you're kind of celebrity but not
really but you're eating alone at ihot
you'll do in the morning yeah you're not
really a celebrity but you'll do because
this is the best they can
you're a problem if they're desica doing
you know Alabama whatever you're a
cut-stone to their past yeah you're that
guy or does that character I my mom
loves you
ah well that's how you know you're
getting older yeah that having looking
in the mirror one time I
I was lonely enough to be dragged to a
frat house and I looked around I was
like well I'm 38 these kids are 18 and
and and I'm kind of the center of
attention and one kid was going to my
phone to see if there are any
celebrities uh-huh that he would
recognize and I was just like this I
might kill myself right now but I'm too
pathetic to leave I kind of want to stay
a little longer
and I had to get the [ __ ] out of there I
can remember getting high in the
backseat of a Toyota Corolla of the one
of the waitresses and a Busboys of the
club in Cleveland in the parking
structure and we we rolled down the
windows you know it's to let the smoke
out but we didn't roll him down very low
because it was [ __ ] freezing sure in
Cleveland yeah in the winter which is
when I
booked it that's yeah I remember getting
high and thinking that's why Buffalo
when they go you want to Buffalo in
January [ __ ] you great yeah in fact when
I did a club in Buffalo
there was a fight that broke out in the
middle of my act and like full-on
fistfight with tables flying and they
wouldn't I was like should we stop the
show and the owner got on the back my
good nope nope we're going to take care
of it well away and they just let the
fight happened a hockey brawl yeah and
then eventually it cleared out and I
continued on with my set as if it's a
good thing I grew up in an Irish boozy
family where you're used to like nothing
to see here folks
yeah yeah just drunk guys burning out
their angry spirit yeah it's all over I
was in Kansas City and I was doing
Stamford and sons or Sanford and Son
scammer and the name of the club
yeah it's called Sanford and Son and
that's right and it by the way it's in a
mall and then in the middle of nowhere
and I'm all but a mall in the middle of
nowhere where they have those stores
that like the jockey outlet you know
those kinds of stores if you know what I
mean and then other stores like you know
socks and races different socks like
there's nothing to do here and there's a
Starbucks of course so and there's a
Dave & Buster's he had all the food
where you end up beating every every
meal because that's all they're the
worst food in the world but yep that's
right and yeah and it there was a
blizzard
yeah blizzard happen and they had that
well nobody was going to show up to my
show and they didn't and I I was I was
stuck I was stuck in my hotel room
and I never forgot I think it was Will
Arnett one of my buddies was doing some
big movie and he had his own TV show and
then Bradley Cooper was starting to get
famous these were all my kind of friend
contemporaries I miss and then yeah
Brett all right and then yeah and then a
couple other guys were just killing it
and I was I remember sitting in the Best
Western I think it was the Best Western
doesn't matter it was like that or the
Best Western is probably like better
than it was
okay of stuff most knew it was very new
clean and I was sitting in my in my
hotel room alone while it was
blizzarding out and there's nowhere to
go
and there was a Bible I remember I
opened during there was a Bible and
there's a Bible and there was a and then
I and there was porn I could have
watched on TV there was a like literally
porn and I was like I could watch porn
and read the but that's where I'm at
right now your choices as it yeah and
then I this is so weird but it was
nighttime and I got hungry and I walked
I had rented a car and I was walking
down this business bang bang and I swear
to god this this beat-up
Toyota let's just call it Corolla Lana
why don't we bring it back and these
dudes these are what looked like migrant
workers I mean long hair but but like
they look mean and I swear to god the
guy goes I've never I've never felt
threatened where I was worried and I'm
in Kansas in a blizzard and the guy goes
hey man want to play with us you want to
come play with us and I was like I'm
about to get [ __ ] robbed or killed or
raped I never forgot I Vic it was a
sexual kind of weird predatory thing and
I went I went police as police I just
pointed over there and got a police over
there
I just kind of randomly pointed and said
police and that kind of uh and I was it
was [ __ ] terrifying I would have just
disappeared in a puff of of snow no
trace of Brian as he's dragged into a
car anyway I did [ __ ] the guys but the
point is I'm sure at least here's a part
of you had to say like it it's always a
little bit of a compliment to be
threatened with with for a ride to go
threaten gang rape yeah by migrant
workers least you know you still got I
still give it a to build got it um I
know the day I remember the day I
stopped being molested as a child I
thought I've lost it
I've lost my books I remember my
grandmother talking about the she knew
she was getting older when men stop
looking at her mmm yeah so and I said I
still find you attractive yeah yeah yeah
I did it with her too this is the kind
of show you got to do and then to walk
around chin just cackling Oh
they're kicking off that's right you
know something shin it's got a piece on
him by that you're now no longer doing
Santa because you've kind of you've
always been working like you played the
agent I mark Kirstie Alley freaking out
how good you are as the agent on fat
actress remember we did that show
together yes and you played a guy and I
think you had a bit of an accent you had
a bit of a southern yeah it was a real
there was a real agent her real agent
and she hoped that I would Midd
proximate yeah I'm Emma Kim so I just
did my best you did
yes that was a really fun show actually
I know I know
you know where they went wrong they
should have treated it like it was a
very serious show and don't let him
smell the joke and I think that they
tried to do the opposite and then you
know it was just a bit of a rookie
mistake and and it's it's really common
I think not and not necessarily I don't
know if it was the producers it was
probably the studio people or the
network people who yeah they especially
back then now they're much more
comfortable with like let it play a
little more straight you don't have to
have a joke every five seconds you know
or a lot of dramas they'll let things
you know bleed they're mixing it up
here's the problem now like for example
with the Goldbergs and things like this
what what kills you in these TV shows is
that they sell advertising space so to
squeeze in an extra 20 seconds 40
seconds what do they do they shorten the
time the pauses between the act I know
that the timing ROM reduces well yeah
what I was dragged to show you're
producing and running oh the Sean doing
right now is called nobodies it's on TV
land and it is created by three friends
three old friends from The Groundlings
which is a theatre that I'm from and
then it's you guys you guys you know
Mike McDonald was a yeah I mean you're
you're stabbing you're sort of an
all-star in terms of a groundling but if
you think about who came out of the
groundlings oh it wasn't it wasn't it
can you go through the list for a second
little Errol Cheri Oteri Maya Rudolph on
a gas tire Chris Kattan
uh Chris Parnell Kristen Wiig Lisa
Kudrow Cheryl Hines uh dude I mean we
need Steve Carell come out of there
no you second city yeah and I'm probably
I mean I'm sure I'm leaving out my key
day taran killam
taran killam so many just goes on and on
so many people and then tons and tons of
writers and producers well I always say
the people who come to LA they go I want
to be an actor I go to The Groundlings
yeah I just I just know what their track
record is they're great acting teachers
I was nice in class forever this ivana
chubbuck there's Howard fine this too it
all kinds of different hills playoffs
great but there's something about The
Groundlings that like Rachael Harris
raised there it's another one at least
well they and they also teach I think
they encourage you that what's good is
they encourage you to go for character
and to write
and so that's truly like for me that I
think that's how I've ever gotten
how whatever I've gotten has been
partially because there was a writing
element I know if you can lie implies
you know if you can write your own stuff
then regardless what kind of show you're
on you know you can improvise a good
line of dialogue or you can write your
own vehicle or how long were you on
MADtv I did send you get you to ten
years I did ten ten [ __ ] year and our
ships just passed yeah I only did two
years ago fired for the second I wasn't
coming up with characters here's the
thing um yeah I bet I would I would have
loved to abort with you I would had a
blast but you were on for ten goddamn
years
yeah I was I mean you're the
longest-running MADtv alum because the
show was 14 years right right I came
into year four and left what the year
before were you a bit of a were you when
you were an OG and you must have been a
bully did you blow these a new kid
I don't recall her than everybody I
don't think so I don't think it was a
bully I definitely I loved when new
people came on especially when they were
good yeah that was just like I can
remember like when Ike Barinholtz came
on and I pulled him aside and said
you're you're [ __ ] great hold on to
this job you're a blast to work with
yeah would you have done any different
would you stayed ten years or not uh I'm
I'm glad I did I mean I knew because I
didn't get on I got on the show late you
know I was like ten years practically
older than ever
even when I first got on the show yeah
and I knew how hard it was to get a job
so like the people that were anxious to
bail which everybody was it seemed um I
knew that a job was hard to find
I felt dude I felt the examine just had
been auditioning in New York for so long
and when I say so long I mean for years
that was plenty of time for me to
realize that I was that that when I was
on TV and I got this job it was
literally like holding it in a headlock
yeah I say this about this podcast look
man you know I make money on this
podcast how much I make a fortune
i I own a helicopter I'm going to give
you my chopper phone number but you I
mean the fact that I have a steady
source of income on this podcast I do it
twice a week do we get I think we're
gonna get maybe 11 million downloads
this month I don't even know what to say
about it but the but bottom line is I am
never letting this [ __ ] go it's that
trauma of being an actor back in the day
ya didn't know whether and when I got
fired from MADtv I thought I was going
to go on to do huge things and you're
right everybody on the show is like get
me off the show I want friends I want my
own well then you then you realize oh
I'm I'm getting back into the room with
everybody else
yep and I better win that audition and
there's no second place and I have to be
number one out of the [ __ ] thousand
people and there's first five people
that look exactly like you do and kind
of do more better or better for it yeah
it's uh yeah I mean I never get anything
from auditions anyway it's almost always
like for people I've already worked me
to whatever and in fact uh that even
when I was on MADtv and knew like I I
just couldn't put on another wig or I
didn't want to you know didn't see what
the baby character one more time I
started I asked to direct was another
thing to because they like they're
pretty cheap yeah as far as TV jobs go
so I sort of said alright if you're not
going to give me you know the big bag of
money let me do more things and try and
learn a new trade so that I have
something to fall back on
so when I went back out and I'm really
glad I did
cuz I ended up directing a bunch you're
doing a lot of you directed a live you
drink a lot of TV and I know yeah I was
talking to your directing shitload yeah
I've done like uh like over 100 episodes
that's a great job do you not love that
it's it's great they're there there are
funny things about it it's made me I
think it's probably made me a better you
were saying like were you a bully on
MADtv I probably I wouldn't say I was
but I definitely I'm sure I looked at
things as an actor does I took a lot of
things for granted and I said much more
like aware of how hard everybody else
around is working yeah what all the
people that show up way before you ever
get there I do lead way after you leave
and how hard how they're all just trying
to help you look good yeah the quality
of people I think in the business who
are behind the camera is second to none
yeah I feel like grips and the crew are
the people at first of all they live
somewhere way out on a horse farm right
right and early like north of Valencia
you [ __ ] two hours three hours the
grill off at 3:00 they're up at 3:00
they're there at 5:00 yep their smile on
their face they'll eat they'll eat
ground chuck and like and be half
marathon yeah and be and and power
through the whole [ __ ] day right it's
incredible and then their last to leave
and they'll drive again for three hours
their backup yeah it's unbelievable I
was directing a show that I won't say
what it was but there was an actress who
had been brought to the set maybe ten
minutes earlier than we needed her so
she was kind of giving me a hard time
about it even though I wasn't I didn't
say bring me that actress that's all
there's a whole group of people that do
all that but she was coming to me to
just sort of set it straight and while
we were having this conversation or I
would say I was listening to her
complain there was a wardrobe girl who
was just kind of fixing her stuff and
making her look good and the Wardrobe
girl was pregnant like nine years pretty
already
hop and crowning yeah and the the the
play the actress made to me was like I
could
like this is ten minutes I could have
been spent with my child in my dressing
room I had to leave her and she was
crying and then she walked away be sort
of wood then was magnums like just let's
just not have it happen again
type of thing oh thanks and then she
left and the pregnant wardrobe girl just
burst into tears and she said I haven't
seen that day me in four days because I
have leave her home and I have one I'm
awake and she's complaining that she
tested leave her in her trailer when she
could go see her baby anytime she just
lost it and I just thought like oh my
god remember this you know yeah remember
this it's called perspective yeah yeah
yeah I mean so that's why I always like
is that saying there was a book I read
one time it said and the old wise guy in
the book said happiness is wanting what
you have and I want what I have
I I have to say that maybe now I think
part of the good thing about reading the
newspaper or reading history it's going
to sound silly but I really mean this
for people who are younger it gives you
real perspective on how how much worse
it could be and easy oh yeah yeah so
many people so you know listen I get to
do what I love I'm the best in the world
at it everybody yeah that's the main
point of that Commerce it really is it
really is so you're now directing it
tell me the name of the TV show again
it's called nobodies alright it's a
within it it stars I petty nobodies okay
but it's executive produced along with
me
by Melissa McCarthy Oh Ben Falcone
another and most McCarthy another
growling by the end by the way my
student from epic when I was a teacher
so she and her husband Ben met in my
class 20 years ago and then the three
stars of the show are also all
groundings
who were in my class and it's kind of I
mean the short version is like you know
when you're starting out and you're all
in your your 20s or whatever and you're
like someday we should work on us we
could make a show together yeah like 20
years later that actually
happened Wow and so what was Melissa
like when you when you taught her uh
hilarious I mean truly
I didn't there wasn't a thing I had to
teach her wasn't a thing other than just
like oh yeah that's a good girl with
that well it's funny because her
[ __ ] in a sink made her she was so
[ __ ] funny and bright Mohammed made
her she was not you're denying sirs over
Groundlings on the day one day one yeah
just I mean Rory yeah you can see it I
mean she's just on some people are just
[ __ ] undeniable krandall a great girl
and by the way Kristen Wigg so there
Melissa's on the show Ben's in the show
Kristen Whigs in the show she guest
stars occasionally uh I'm in it
tellers yeah Jason Bateman really I love
Jason Allison Janney Kristen Bell like
it wow it's really and it's all people
that and then tons and tons of
groundling so you haven't heard of but
you will I want to come in and do it
where am I gonna do something I don't
warry find out for you I mean I think
you're a really good actor unusually
thank you let me put let me play the
hero there are no heroes okay
not it sound amazing it's really fun and
then you know like obviously we do write
it but there's lots and lots of play you
know and you're and you're working with
a bunch of your old friends so like it's
it's the easiest [ __ ] in the world it's
you know why man when you're around
people like that okay that like you're
talking about the joy is that everybody
speaks a language you know that and that
language is humor there's a frequency
that you operate on and there's an
intimacy in that right yeah it's it's I
mean it's truly effortless yes because
if you want to kill me put me on a set
with a bunch of dramatic actors because
I get super [ __ ] bored because I
frankly find them very boring because
they're often quite earnest there's the
Lord haha yes
they're quite earnest and that's a huge
problem I know you're in character Paul
Giamatti doing a movie called The
Hangover to I don't know if you ever
heard of it I haven't yeah well I mean
probably not in the demo yeah so I'm
doing I'm doing that this movie Paul
Giamatti is nominated for a Golden Globe
we're going walk in a set I say dude
congrats it's [ __ ] huge and he goes
yeah yeah I said we don't see me do that
it's just you know
I love being around you guys you're all
comedians and I'm laughing and it's like
the acting gets in the way and I'm on
set in this thing everybody's in costume
and character and they're all kind of
being character you know actors and it's
you know it just gets to be a drag after
all I was like well yeah that's exactly
right when you're with you know Zach
Galifianakis and they're giving you the
they had a helicopter that was coming
sort of did the helices they're the
Michael Jordan of helicopter guys and in
the hangover 2 the helicopter comes up
over the Michael Jordan's a shoe
designer sorry God thank you thank you
helicopter coming over the building
coming over the building and the blade
was coming so [ __ ] close to the like
it was so crazy he was an acrobat that
blade had hit metal would have got
everywhere we would have been
decapitated everything would have blown
up I don't got it and so you have a
safety meeting you know and and it's a
very serious safety meeting and and the
guys so the helicopters going to come up
guys and you know the danger here
obviously is fire or if the blade hits
the building obviously it could be
catastrophic we need you to hit the
ground when you're down on the ground
you come up when the plane comes that
you guys are going to land go down you
know there's a whole process a whole
choreography and zach is like any
questions zach is like yes yeah sure
thanks what color would the helicopter
be yeah he's not funny right i blue I
think it would is it me and Zach it's
not going to work for me I get a red
light a [ __ ] [ __ ] like Corey or
Todd Phillips comes over and gives I
think it was Bradley a note or something
and just try to make it a little bit
more you know like that and rather than
putting is exactly I have it on I have
an app on my phone here and he just
pushes put to the kids Bradley's face
it'll help you with your acting I have
an acting app on your phone you know so
that kind of [ __ ] is so much fun when
you're just around idiot well that my
favorite thing at mad Jimmy they would
they would make us do a sexual
harassment seminar and you know they
have a whole crew and cast everybody is
up in the bleachers of the audience and
then these basically these [ __ ] stiff
lawyers whatever
but they they made this I can't believe
they made the mistake they go why don't
we will do some role-playing and let's
bring the cast members down and so like
it was Mike would you have to do it I
was like I would love to do it and one
of the girls I think it was Nicole
Parker and her you know so now let's
just simulate you know say something
inappropriate - Nicole is like all right
Wow you're what a drawer full of big
black dildos you've got yeah and they're
like what
and then because like would you like to
try one I'm like yes you know she's just
raping me with this big black dildo and
like okay all right this is already
sexual I can smell your [ __ ] from here
is that is that far enough you know
exactly you got a dick on you is that a
balloons at a red balloon to you as a
sticky red balloon happy to see me and
they would never like they didn't they
laugh that nothing like these people
have no that's what the world we're
living it right you're right right we're
living in a world where everybody's
terrified to make a move because your
job and your reputation can be destroyed
with a probe and in mine will I mean
what to what extent I have a job or a
reputation uh I'm like all these people
that are getting hurt they're an actor
whatever but I mean I send you have sent
you some [ __ ] oh my god the things I
said I still have it on my phone
like Michael Michael goes I something
like that I get I get it I get a video
of just a dude bent over with a giant
ball sack and and I haven't seen Mike
Rowe talk to him in like three years
I just get into the triangle come to the
podcast might just get a video of a web
dude bent over with a giant ball sack
and a woman in a lot of lingerie with
with gloves on like a small like MMA
gloves and she's been punching him in
the balls and I know that you're like
fighting I do like fighting good news
good news
relentlessly pounding his balls as he's
screaming in pain but won't get out of
that position I know he's he could he
could walk away but he doesn't know and
I appreciate that I'm going to bring you
up on charges
yeah I'm amazed at how puritanical we
become and I think the narrative is
being driven by the radical left-wing
ideologues or the radical sort of
egalitarians
have no sense of humor who had no
sexuality will their world crazy they're
literally that's the best way to put it
they're litter that that is like I was
at a party actually tell this my act but
I was at a party where I was a bunch of
very liberal Hollywood powerful people
we're all standing around and they were
talking about they were ragging on the
rest of America flyover States aren't we
lucky to be not living where you know no
[ __ ] on middle of the country and
you know here like we have our daughter
and it was a pool party the daughter was
four years old and she was naked which
you know spore who came but she's like
jumping around the water and stuff and
having a blast and like we were able to
raise our child in a liberal environment
you know and we're just so glad to be
able to raise her as opposed to those
uptight conservative flyover country and
then but I never met right and then I go
yeah but didn't think she's a little
young to have be having her [ __ ] shave
and the inhale of it wasn't just air
like I knew I knew I was wrong the
second volume is oh yeah I like crowd
I'm not going and I little after I was
going for absurdity you know because yes
for there's nothing to shave but you
know and I couldn't couldn't back my way
all right it's a great joke at the
expense of a four-year-old it's a great
joke you know it's very funny and
outrageous well yeah because you think
like well if I go super far then they'll
know that it's obviously a joke and now
you I'm on a thread with Will Sasso and
Chris D'Elia and the the amount of
obscenity the amount of horror that goes
on I mean if I would be ruined
I would be ruined because I go out of my
way to be as offensive as I can't court
I have a theory and I'm writing about
this on my stand in my stand-up I think
the white elite these did the
progressive elite and it's usually white
people they're all well-meaning yes but
I don't think they know what to do with
their guilt there is guilt to being so
if you said to the history of this
country there is there wasn't justice
continued there were black ghettos and
every idolater because I because you're
Irish and I'm Sicilian and I had nothing
to do with anything but I believe [ __ ]
off and I come from Sicilian and Irish
in stock go [ __ ] yourself I don't have
any do it I believe in Fairplay I don't
want to see under people be children who
are of color or anybody else not get the
same [ __ ] my kids get I don't like it
I'm all about equality of opportunity I
don't want to enforce equality of
outcome because that's [ __ ] right
but I want to be able which is the word
you can't say no of course not no
because language means everything and
they did you have the speech police out
there and the speech police will will
ruin you will ruin you I'm you used
chocolate out of context man I'm telling
you dude
so so you know for me I think what it is
is it's white it's it's a lot of sort of
powerful progressive white people
typically I'm sorry to say this who
haven't met a whole lot of who don't
really have interaction with people who
work with their hands they haven't done
any military service they haven't done
those things that put you in contact did
this sort of visceral objective contact
with that kind of reality I'm not saying
they don't work hard not saying they
don't have a lot to offer right I'm
trying to be fair here but I think that
their way of dealing with their guilt or
trying to make the world a better place
is that they they try to police other
White's yeah well they're home out of
the force they're like mom I never liked
the hall monitor no no so I need a back
say in the media anything you say is
construed as being racist so this guy
who is an OD seven years old view of
aerolite as that cameras name I used to
watch him play tennis Vitas Gerulaitis
Vitas Gerulaitis Serena Williams is
having a baby with the guy who owns
reddit and he did my podcast back a bit
great guy god bless him she's pregnant
she's the greatest female tennis player
ever not the greatest tennis player but
greatest female tennis player I'm just
looking which of course you can because
there was a debate about that but she's
not and but she's amazing and she's a
phenomenal player and I love watching
her play uh he said oh that baby I
wonder what that baby's going to be at
that milk chocolate now he was just he
was not being racist he was not being
offensive to him I didn't hear what he
said it was a compliment to him it was
like that's gonna be a beautiful baby
right which I would that that's how I
would take it that's how he meant it
right she was Rena Williams she has her
own reason maybe she has a button on
this stuff
she called it races everybody else a lot
of other people did came you know kind
of swarming all over and he went tell me
what did I say that was a food that was
racist right and if you're going to
start calling people racist for that
then what do you call the guy burning
cross in his [ __ ] front lawn because
there are racists right right but it
really does cheapen the word man it does
when you you know so that we have to be
careful with language and I feel like it
really is a blanket like someone like
you who makes something funny as a comic
I feel like the last place that we can
actually speak our mind is on stage well
that and yet not TV anymore
that's one of definitely not although
it's weird we're on the show nobody's
that I'm doing which is also available
on the TV Land app and downloadable and
bin jabal yeah we're we're messing
around let's uh it's probably who I
think it's collected but uh we're trying
to get away to me
that's what that's what why I got into
comedy was the suit I could get away
with you know like and to see what you
if you can turn that or anybody but to
make people laugh chorus but I'm like
there there are people that make jokes
about the Holocaust
why not because they think the Holocaust
is funny but like that's that's also how
you deal with pain in anyway like I mean
the first episode the sketch we did on
MADtv my first my first sketch I ever
did in the world when I got to Los
Angeles
I played Schindler and it was called
Schindler's lost and I couldn't find the
Jews before they're being loaded onto
trains but to save them and she and I'm
driving and she was she couldn't give me
directions
it was the most offensive [ __ ] thing
it was all written by Jewish people it
was also being produced by Jewish people
and Steven Spielberg got wind of it and
said if you oh that's right I remember
you if you if you air this I'll do
everything I can in my power to shut it
down Jon Blanchard who was the second
city badass who directed all three
cities and an amazing director said said
you know how I stand where I stand on it
and so what he goes he says that you
definitely run it you would definitely
run it I say you run the [ __ ] out of it
because it's comedy right and none of us
believe in bulldozing Jews or killing
Jews nobody none of us believe in
genocide we're comedians yeah and
you're right there there are some things
that might be too wrong a lot that I
understand that that's offensive but
there's also something that says art
disturbs comedy kind of shakes you up a
little bit right I mean what else do we
have me oh I say would they win the bad
guys to me I just always hope to do the
impossible and and that's the that's the
fun thing for me is if I can get
somebody to laugh at something that they
would normally not laugh at or if it
like yeah I'd like to see that look in
their face like I shouldn't be laughing
at this but I am well that is that
example the four year olds that's an
outrageous thing to say but it's it's
outrageous like Mike nice yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] funny
uh you know that was one of the things I
actually liked about MADtv I felt like
we went a little farther and a little
harder maybe than some air shows and
like I was the last one to say the real
n-word with the you know pronounced ER
at the end really um yeah on on Fox Wow
um we were doing the sketch was it Aries
Spears a very funny guy he had sort of a
running sketch it was called real
[ __ ] talk and it was like a kind
of a black militant guy and then he you
had usually all black guests and then a
super out-of-touch white guy and I
always that was like my stock in trade
so and they had real rappers on I think
was like exhibited and try to bring this
out get out with you be on YouTube I
think it would be what they call real
[ __ ] talk and I'll be able to l
know which one it is I mean there's only
about nine or ten but anyway we did the
sketch and it it went really well you
know the sketch was basically the same
three times around like right there oh
that's the one right there the one with
exhibitor with you and that one yeah all
right watch this I gotta go with the
tarts baby boom no cranium yeah man I'm
only doing with the strudel
crap whitey oh you haven't lived you've
had a croissant I mean [ __ ] please oh
[Applause]
my [ __ ] god that I hit the button oh
my god
[Applause]
and they let they hear this they did
what year was this right before the Iraq
war yeah damn that was 2003 yeah like so
so so like if you say that and this is
in the context and obviously with you
know Aaron look if they haven't even
since Avenue
they just keep reacting and the the
tally lights were just popping all
around yeah
which Artie Lange tells a story like
this where he was playing basketball you
you can he just kept here in the world
with always black guys and he goes you
know pass the ball inning and everything
just stop but that ain't yours that
ain't your worry well and that was my
dad's my family work but that's the
funny like Rogan was saying that to
Roman was saying just by saying the word
[ __ ] you can get you can get in
trouble people go crazy just when the
word is said right and again I
understand the violence attached that
word there are words like that [ __ ]
used to be a word that was used like it
was an acceptable prejudice when it's
explained to you that that word is used
when some is kicking your [ __ ] head
in for happen to be for liking somebody
of the same sex and still happened oh
okay I get it I get why that would be
offensive when you hear the one when the
word [ __ ] was used and it went a noose
was being wrapped around your neck by a
gang of white people yeah
that's why so when you understand the
history of words and the violence that's
attached them and why the group that's
been oppressed can use it but you can
I'm all about that well that [ __ ] and
then there in the in areas case you're
just being to being comedic the whole
point is that you the character miss
right he's being raised that he's now
allowed that is the whole point of it
but I will say in Aires you know to
Aires credit that was the second take
and so I
sort of said I've got this idea let's
just try it and they didn't know what
was coming and area but areas is great
and then afterward there you know all of
the network people came up like we can't
we were using the first take and Ares
said no you've got to use a second take
yeah no it was really his errand here
behind the raft he wasn't being
disempowered all three of them they oh
[ __ ] they don't [ __ ] and by the way our
audience was largely to comment it's
comedy and it was making the right point
yeah like I was yes you're a that I'm
the [ __ ] though exactly you're not
you're not you know and and that's where
we've lost our way that's where we've
lost them because they're always a
little puritanical literal sort of uh
and it's a form up it's a purge it's
sort of a form of them like it's a
fundamentalism it's a form of
fundamentalism how dare you how dare you
say that word you're taking power away
from the people that have been oppressed
and it's like they want out they want to
show the other group that they're the
other part the other whites essentially
their colleagues that they're even less
prejudiced than the other then you know
they're right there everybody is so busy
trying to show how virtual a virtuous
they are that there everyone's lost
their sense of humor so now it's exactly
what happens beings are still horrible
people or human beings are still
horrible often that's never going to
change you're not going to change the
world by that but now we're also going
to not be able to laugh at anything
oh well but but human beings uh the
extremists hijack the public dialogue
when if you were in Mao Zedong's China
and you are not not wholeheartedly
committed to the Communist Party you
would get outed and killed or put in
jail Pol Pot's camp other humorless play
like all those places are there you know
LeCompte ideology yeah yeah an ideology
as you're either right or you're wrong
there is no middle ground so room for
humor or metaphor are you kidding me
there is right there is a pure or there
is the soiled there is gold or there
[ __ ] that is what an ideology is so and
human beings obviously this is going to
sound crazy but we occupy
a whole spectrum don't we we are sinners
and we're saints and we're always
something in between that might my
favorite things you got rid of all if
you killed all the record unquote
racists you'd still have racism because
we're all tribal and we all have right
we all discriminate and we all judge and
we all have a little of that in us Louis
CK's joke um which i think is brilliant
because I'm a little racist I hope I
hope he's already done this on a special
getting is good I'm a little racist he
goes I'm a little racist you like when I
walk into a pizza joint and I see a
bunch of black women making my pizza oh
my god right well I get it you know it's
a great joke because [ __ ] you we're
human
yeah stop it yeah I'm glad we settled
all these problems we really we fixed a
lot of things yeah yeah thank you so
much for your courage for your comedic
kearney
uh you're so [ __ ] good though
surprised you don't act more I mean it's
your choice but you know what was the
dream role uh give like a same favorite
actor come home I gotta get so many I
mean I think my I would kill to be on
veep goddamn it's a great shower I'm so
good that I I'm not even jealous of it
I'm I'm actually I don't know how they
all do it like I know they I don't know
how the writers write every character
brilliantly and there's a and how a
director can get everyone um firing on
all cylinders I don't know how the
actors and she's brilliant she's amazed
but they're all brilliant that whole
cast is brilliant and a jealous of it
and scared of it and intimidated by it
and I'd kill to be on a show like that
yeah I feel that way I feel that way
about Tina Fey when I see the way she
writes to she's kind of terrifyingly
good too is horrifyingly good like 30
rock like I'd watch it not good she has
ground but she was a second city yeah I
mean I she just blows me away sometimes
when I watch I'm just like huh [ __ ] are
you that good a writer yeah and uh Kimmy
Schmidt is like a show that I mean watch
it it's like a machine gun of jokes like
it's boom boom boom boom I mean there's
no joke after joke after joke and you're
like wait even the setup was a joke like
it's amazed and when you
been doing it for as long as you and I
have and they're able to surprise you
over and over again that's where I'm
like I'm very
yeah it's intimidating it's actually
like you're you're in awe
I don't even laugh because I'm rightly
blown away yeah I got by myself just
watching it like when I remember as a
young man watching Ghostbusters
the first one I was so entertained I was
so into the movie that all I could do is
bite my nails
I couldn't even laugh because I was I
was so I didn't know what to do have you
had somebody like I've had one time a
show there was a woman in the front row
of one of my stand-up shows and she was
literally just like this are you of
course and you know of course it's the
one face you can see and then it black
out here and she came up afterwards and
said I I love the show I go you stood
there with your arms crossed the whole
time yeah and she's like oh I didn't
know like it that's what I do
if I really love what you're doing I'll
probably be the guy that's why you
haven't laughed at all
that's why I haven't last one and that
one yeah I probably would watch you and
and be that way because I'd be marveling
it sort of like your ability to
character and put it all the I mean I
think that's what I do when I watch
friends of mine that are really good
like I like yeah so does that to me will
set so kind of blows me away with how
amazing he is at impressions and how
amazing is it coming up with original
characters like he's done [ __ ] on Tim
and a podcast to me where I was in the
thing and I was like just I was just
watching him and I was just like I don't
know how you do that and he was really
good I mean when I got on the first got
on the show he was already there but he
was only like 22 or something oh yeah I
was doing ha he was doing impressions
which I was fine I think there those are
the hardest yeah but he was doing
spot-on impressions like I think he's
really got heard you ever see his um
Randy Newman yes I mean because he has
to sing too
yes uh I think he I think he's the best
Frank Kelly I know is maybe the best
ever but but I think Sasso is actually
better because all due respect to Frank
Sasso is better because he can do the
other stuff he can sing he can write
write act like it he said
an amazing actor - yeah yeah I would
love to Saleem do a drama actually I
think so in acting but Frank Caliendo
truly his especially the set you know
because he's got physically you know
he's a shorter guy and you know he's
kind of a I got our luck but um so he
can't always look exactly like but which
doesn't matter but when he does like
when we were at the table reason MADtv
and you know your your face is kind of
in the script following along he would
just be hearing and his he sounded like
that person was in the room it was so
crazy and I thought his Bush was the
best Bush in anybody ever did there's no
doubt and his and his other Bush I
thought he was saying it I'm ten years
old so you give me an opening and I take
this stupid on it lowest hanging fruit
but um Oh somebody something told me
okay I was telling somebody we know
mutually that I was doing your podcast
and she said something like how long
till you show each other your Dinks
personal don't call it a dink
because think sounds tiny it sounds like
a little piece of metal and my day I
like to say did yeah we got to get some
air in it cuz it's so heavy hey bro come
on let me show you my day you know I
mean there's something ominous about
that I'm going on here I want to show
you my day
were you in Buffalo or Kansas City I was
in can't say thank you thank you during
a blizzard if you were you in the car I
was good you were playing a migrant
worker
I thought those black every way off and
that dink let me show you my dink you're
doing I can't stand those kinds of
things my gang where'd you grow up I
grew up in Orange County you did yeah
when did you know you were funny that's
a question I will never answer because I
think you can't answer it without
sounding like an [ __ ] and I'll tell
you what I mean we did an interview in
the very early years of MADtv they would
they would take like two or three of us
and they would you know because one
wasn't a celebrity so they like
let's get to what you take two right and
some interviewer asked us at what age
did you know you were a comic genius and
I knew not to answer the question that
way but the other person I was with said
for me I guess it was kindergarten and I
was like you don't do that like this
lost yeah you I knew I liked comedy very
early because I grew up in a funny
family who makes you laugh the hardest
you have a favorite comic Wow um I think
I'd probably have to say Bill burr bill
burr is pretty amazing isn't he I
another so many I mean yeah I really
love so many of them how about actors
communicators I think for me it was Bill
Murray ER or apartment Joe Harmon mm-hmm
I love them both and Phil Harmon by the
way rest his soul was such a nice guy
there's a groundling he was a groundling
- yeah did you work with him I did I
mean not I like he came back a well
they're all pretty well cuz he was a
ground yeah yeah yeah Phil Hartman in
fact tried to he got me an audition for
SNL but he came back and did like a
charity event and then had me do some
improv with him and it was him Jon
Lovitz Travis Dennis Miller
they were both growling no but they were
Jon Lovitz was yeah but we just he Phil
when did this Ling or maybe it was
Dennis's charity it was Dennis's charity
and so they all did it and Phil asked me
to do it and I got to perform with all
these greats and he was such a such a
quality human being yeah Phil [ __ ]
man funny III remember Colin Rogan about
it yeah after somebody tell me about it
and I was just like what his wife
because I remember a roving used to talk
about his wife well that was you know
it's funny because when I did that shell
it was I think it was it like a week
before it happened yeah and she was
there and like yeah you know be wise you
wouldn't know you would not know no
drugs
yes stuff I mean yeah nobody did blow
crack or meth and it worked out I mean
nobody's like well I had a lot of
problems and then I kind of up my dosage
of heroin and then things fell into
place I think
found the place I did do meth for three
years and I have to say I got better at
jujitsu um that's never been the case
right my room got cleaner my skin got
more holes in it I finally found that a
string in my face I've been trying to
dig for thank you I can't imagine you on
coke I've done blood before I'm sure
yeah no no but not a lot because I don't
like it I think it's terrible I think
it's awful and I hate what it does to
people yeah I've had people say I've had
people give me blow whether I like this
stuff is sticky it's so pure and I'm
like oh I don't I'm not a coke guy and
then I'll do it just to see if it's
because I love the feeling of coffee
with a buzz the coffee gives me I think
I have so much dopamine already like I
have serotonin whatever good I have good
levels that that it just makes me become
a little bit of a rat where I'll sit
there and I and I move my mouth and I
don't like myself so I don't do cocaine
and now I don't do cocaine like now I
would never do below but here's why
because I think that the industry I
don't know if you know this but you know
you know you're a cocaine well also to
get the it from plant to powder requires
a lot of murder and there's a no unit
and then I have good practice good labor
laws ah I don't tell me about how you
[ __ ] eat - locally source yeah [ __ ]
yourself while you're doing blow blow is
a murderous it's a murderous product
there's a lot of um you know communities
are destroyed and [ __ ] you know all
kinds of [ __ ] happens in Mexico and you
know I'm saying like so I feel guilty I
feel guilty getting high I love that you
said you don't like yourself when you
were high on coke I loved myself when I
have Coke that was the product I thought
I was amazing and really I've got a lot
of interesting things to say oh no
that's Rach no no you'll start a
business together no thanks I was the
work store I mean I did it so few times
I never really liked it yeah yeah I can
you and I doing blow would be like while
we start a shoot coming it'll call it
Michael Jordan but we'll spell it with a
G if that's
got a [ __ ] idea you have yeah chin
can sing the jangles chin will you ever
a coke I know no it seems like it's fun
that Woo's guy did you damn I love I
love I love red wine and uh it's red
wine and a little pot would be yeah I
like red wine I like a little sipping
tequila and I like to [ __ ] her I'm sorry
I did I did that another podcast getting
a dog with high you ever heard about it
a dog with higher high with Doug it's
called getting done oh hi mr. Benton I
I'm done no I haven't well literally
it's like you know a smaller room like
this and they just pass out the pot and
you get high on camera on the podcast
and then and then talk about I've done
that on Rogan I've smoked weed with
Rogan and I've gotten so I don't know
what kind of weed he has but you gotta
be careful you're like him if Joe Rogan
is Batman you would be his Robin yeah
well I'm Joe Rogan light he and I could
refer to me yeah you know I'm Joe Rogan
before they put the water in and he's
here he stretches I've never actually
met Joe you never read met Joe goes one
of my closest oldest friends Joe is till
might be the most unique person in many
ways very hard to pin down he hunts he
can sketch plays pool he's an amazing
artist he can draw really well and he's
and he's saying information art oh my
god well he's an insane impressionist
there's some things people don't know
about him one is he can draft he can
draw like what the best of him he's a
not below pro as a pool player he is um
he's an incredible impressionist he's as
good as almost anybody and a huge racist
and a massive mess yeah and and but he
can draw he's got a piece on him he's a
and he's a you know took Taekwondo as
far as it could go like he's done he's
got his interest now he's obsessed with
archery he kills animals with a bow and
arrow a man yeah he's a maniac he always
has game meat in his freezer which
reminds me I have to go raid his freezer
and yet he also has with the main thing
that I love about him is he said as big
as accomplishment is
it's achieving peace of mind because
when he was younger he went he had a
very tough childhood and the world was a
very dangerous place and he kept
everybody man at arm's length I was one
of the few people allowed in but he was
tough because you know he was he was
basically terrified of the world and and
you know if you got too close he punch
her kick you away you know it was that
kind of thing but he found peace of mind
he I've never met anybody who's more
ruthless with themselves he's always
growing like he's never not worked out
right there's no one more disciplined
there's no one who doesn't show and his
podcast is the biggest podcast in the
world is it yes and the main thing that
I really appreciate about him is that he
has taken that podcast where it used to
be just kind of talking to dudes about
fighting or comedians he has the leaders
of thought in every fiha that a science
that's how i still college it was like
there was somebody I was interested in
who was there writing history and he had
that's author on Dan Carlin yeah I've
had some amazing people yeah and I
continues to yeah and I and he was
obviously he was conversant in it and he
clearly if he hasn't formally educated
he educated himself well he's also got
interest he's a maverick and he has
other Mavericks on so Kelly Brogan um
she's a she's a psychiatrist not a
psychotherapist a sec how she can
prescribe medication well she went to
medical school on every number I do have
her tied to every member and she I
listen to podcast and I I appreciate it
very much
she's written a book called a mind of
your own and what she found was that
when she was treating these psych
patients and she would get the hardest
cases the first thing that they do is
they prescribe you medication and
medication psycho farm pharmacology is a
hit-or-miss kind of science yeah
sometimes you're on three different
medications seven different medications
that then they up the doses lower the
dosage and it's it doesn't always work I
know somebody who's bipolar who it
doesn't work for and it's hit or miss it
does by the way I want to be fair I'm
sure it saves some lives I'm sure it
does something for people but I know a
couple people that she got very very
frustrated with the world and and
started to look at what other
alternatives were
and the orthodoxy in the medical
community is just you got a problem
let's give you the I let me person give
you a right prescription and I kind of
appreciate that he's showcasing people
that are kind of turned coasts
physicians and sort of people that are
thinking outside the box right because
these problems need to be thought of
outside the box and like for example I
had plaque psoriasis so you know what
that is I only heard about it because
there's like some medicine that is
always advertised Humera yeah so I had
plaque psoriasis and I would get every
year I would start getting it on my legs
so if I wore shorts it was not a pretty
sight man I mean it looked like like I
had some kind of crazy disease and I
went to the dermatologist a
you know it's an autoimmune disease it's
the cells cluster together and if
there's nothing we can do about it but
let me give you a steroid cream and let
me give you another cream they really do
cream the cream would never work and
then I started getting on my face and my
ears and I was like this something's
[ __ ] up man this is bad so I did some
research and I did some time reading and
I did reading by other doctors not and I
did some reading on to science and the
literature and the first thing that a
dermatologist will tell you and I've
spoken to a number of them is it's not
related to diet problem is that it is
related to diet and you read a book like
the plant paradox you loot read these
different books where doctors are going
I've been treating patients for 35 years
I've done my own experiments on this and
it looks like corn soy wheat especially
these whole wheats with all the lectins
in them all these sort of like you know
that the plant when you have the fiber
you use the fiber use brown rice this is
the fiber and the plan is keeps the
insects and birds away
it creates it's got poisons in it those
poisons also affect you long story short
when I took out cow dairy when I took
out [ __ ] wheat my psoriasis went away
it went away and my plaque psoriasis
that they said was only getting worse
and that they were only given medication
for it just went away I don't have that
problem anymore now be careful about
using anecdotal evidence but by the way
since then I've read a number of books
that point doctors they yeah and I went
to a doctor who think
box he's a medical doctor but he went
try not eating wheat and your bloat will
go away
try not eating wheat and your psoriasis
may go away try keeping cow protein out
and see what happens
bingo it's [ __ ] work not placebo
because I'm a skeptic you know I was
like yeah whatever but you know so Rogan
seems to be showcasing people that have
answers to problems that we're told
don't have answers to that's what I like
oh cool yeah so anybody out there has
psoriasis try taking all week not just
gluten-free just take it out no corn no
soy that's right out and write to me
tell me if it works and no [ __ ] berry
except for a sheep or goat dairy thanks
guys Brennan skin talk how do I assist
pairs of psoriasis uh yeah cuz Humira
which works my buddy's got really bad
psoriasis Humera works but it ups your
chances of having lymphoma and things
like that so what I see so far off well
yeah anyway I don't have any conditions
you don't do you know you just have that
Irish that good Irish stock the the type
that actually that's not true I do have
one thing spring virus Irish stock they
it's uh called hemochromatosis and what
it is is in your blood
iron you know is bad for you yeah
certain yeah at a certain level and
hemochromatosis is something about your
liver that it can't process iron and it
so just builds up in your blood to an
unhealthy level and then it can give you
you can die of cirrhosis from never
never even having a drink it's liver
that's pretty significant viruses before
I start saying you have nothing going on
wait but here's the treatment and this
is the weirdest thing there's no fix for
it other than they have to let out your
blood oh yeah because then you create
new blood and what it does is as a
percentage of your blood the iron level
goes down all the new blood doesn't have
iron in it yet so you have to like
change your oil cos exact it depends on
who you are where you are with it and
I've only had to do it like once a year
but they just once here you don't have
vampire bats that living or
but the weird thing is is like and they
take I've donated blood before but I
never they take out so much that you
kind of yeah it's almost like you get
drunk you I think if I was ever to kill
myself I would probably slit my wrists
yeah only because it actually doesn't
hurt and you just kind of really you
just bleed out yeah but it just is
terrifying man they the needle that they
have is like a
you know normally it's like a pin this
is like a section it's really and they
take a bite out they take a lot out so
much that I don't even know if you're
allowed so that there's there's a doctor
that I did talk about phlebotomy a
phlebotomy yeah because this doctor
talked about what women tend to not die
as often stroke and of you know and and
one of the corners are various today
they bleed yeah and he said give blood
once a year and your cholesterol your
blood won't be as sticky and it's the
same idea which I can't give blood
because I had hepatitis A as a kid yeah
from eating [ __ ] or actually just living
in the third world or just being a first
class Rimmer yeah I was a [ __ ] real
Rimmer that as a kid I you guys were
being fun who had what they called the
taste see her first class and Rimmer
top not CH an a-plus Rimmer you [ __ ]
Rimmer didn't I had a girl say that to
me one time my favorite thing having my
ass he'd she was super cute but I was
like it's an aggressive thing to say too
bad as a challenge I'll do it but
goddamn it and this was this was
happening when you're a kid yeah I was
that I was a kid of 23
um yeah I I've had I've had a woman I've
talked about this before get into the
old bunny hole and really start working
a tongue around the old rim and more I
was like you're trying to get in my
bunny hole so you got a Spanish for
poopoo I had a problem with I mean how I
mean can you not kill us we kill my
peace with both thumbs like you're
looking for something serious and then
get that [ __ ] that that lizard tongue
way up in there I was
Paul I'm standing there like what the
[ __ ] is going on here man you would want
to anything I was standing in the
bathroom bent over the sink I could with
tears with tears coming down my my boy
cheeks I want to say boy cheeks again I
was twenty sixty something I'm always
really paranoid I want to say something
like that I was 42 and my wife is gonna
die I was married to you [ __ ] no
I didn't mean it I'm doing math um yeah
I had some I put up some numbers Mike
and that's the point bro I'll put up
some [ __ ] numbers we've been doing
[ __ ] what you do over the weekend I
[ __ ] a rimmed a first-class Rimmer I
liked it there kind of pauses in this
pocket is this applause no no pauses at
all I'm are you you do you are you
afraid of silence no um I'm really not
as I get older um you know what I get
older I'm afraid I swear to god I'm less
so much less afraid of death I just
don't want to leave my kids behind
how many did to my life year older than
nine like I met the I met the younger
one you met a younger one I just don't I
don't want anybody else raising them
they might not be nice to them I have
things I want to teach them and that
that's important and I'm sure well you
know it's like a drag to have the lid
wow what is uh what otherwise I would
die
sounds isolating I love I love my
niece's are over and there's spending
two weeks with my house is okay it's
chaos with two dogs but I kind of like
it I kind of like the noise really yeah
and I used to I used to I grew up with
this Italian in say my mother loved the
mob where did you grow up move oh of
course she called it a mob scene well
not that mob you silly goose
um ah but she was she just making pizza
thriller yeah they made early it's about
you they're terrible where did you grow
in I grew up all over the world
Philippines India Greece Saudi Arabia
Lebanon Pakistan I moved to States when
I was 14
yes I went to boarding school in
Massachusetts college in Washington DC
at American University where I studied
history ladies and gentlemen I then went
to New York and worked at Lehman
Brothers I then decided I had to be a
great actor and I became the greatest
actor and known to me I work my first
job I went to business school and was a
loan officer in a bank get the [ __ ] out
I'm not kidding
where'd you go to business school USC I
know yeah before you came to your senses
I in fact you could a you a good
businessman are you good with your money
and all that I'm good with my money you
are yeah I mean I'm mostly just
conservative about it you have family
that gives your family of money
my parents were self-made like they were
Irish all my grandparents came from
Ireland we were all cleaning ladies and
worked like I think my grandpa worked in
a candy store you know comedy totally
yeah yeah and so I grew up my parents
were very much all about work really
hard don't do anything dumb and because
the world is a harsh place man my
biggest worry is that my kids are going
to do something one dumb thing my son
one dumb thing all it takes it all it
takes for your life to be and I've done
so many dumb things but I've just been
lucky yeah no [ __ ] it's all by one dumb
thing yes to the wrong group of guys on
a Saturday night and some [ __ ] happens
and a nobody dies or maimed for life and
your life is done and with the internet
ah thank God I didn't have a [ __ ]
internet you it's on it's it lives
forever
took your pants down you wagged your
dicks at somebody yeah you got in a
fight and then you you know whatever you
did your employer can look that up
that's one of the reasons why frankly
why I don't like to do it's not like it
happens every day but even after shows
or whatever I don't love having my
picture taken on people's phones because
it's it's it's out there forever oh yeah
and I don't know like people can figure
out where you are that you're not at
home worse than that it's worse than
that so there is infinity
and the line was it was basically how
big brother was watching and how
technologies came to a point where the
NSA can watch you as you have drones you
know you have these drones that we have
drones that can or planes that can take
pictures every second or less of the
entire Los Angeles basin so that if
you're in a van and you commit a robbery
they can follow where that van is it's
very effective they took down a drug
cartel radio lab did a thing on it but
here's the bigger thing in the audition
I did he said you know someday they're
going to have digital archivists and
those digital archivists can can you can
can tell your grandchildren who you
really were because every text you've
ever set I'm dead I'll be best Jo I'm
Bao every picture everything you ever
said there is there is a digital record
of it it is out there it will be you
there will be programs and people that
can dig it all up and put it into a book
well sell it to your relatives or your
enemies that is going to exist so yeah
I'm [ __ ] and I think we all are I also
do believe though that when we die that
essentially is what is yeah that is what
the afterlife is everything everything
is just known every you everything about
you is known yeah that's just it yeah
and I don't think I think it's everybody
knew everything about me I don't think
it would be that incriminating because
I'm not a bad guy yeah like I'm a [ __ ]
and I'm not a bad guy embarrassed like
I'm a pervert and I'm you know what I
mean like okay I like me and sasso it's
all it's all sex related in one way or
another at all or it's outrageous
behavior but I don't mean it right so
yeah I don't think that a you I don't
touch children I don't feel animals I
don't you know he murders yes those
things are you know there are certain
things that I would never that I can
never excuse if you abuse children then
then no matter who you are what you've
done you're you're dead to me
right I'm thinking of the bad things
like when I don't know if
somebody was telling me about their
problems and my mind drifted well that's
that's a great example like that's a
great ago like our thinking about like
the other day friends tell me something
and by the way they had told me this
before many times so one the first time
but um and I I just were thinking about
what I was going to make for dinner and
I just not know like what I had a friend
is going on the permanent record
oh yeah but you but you know hey that's
called being human and we've all been
that way it's like my friend has said
one time a buddy of mine got pancreatic
cancer and he was going to die and he
did die and we my buddy felt guilty I
said why cuz I'm just gonna say this to
you and I guess I'm already catching I'm
already Wow because I already kind of
have sect that he's going to die and I
don't want to see him anymore oh I
thought you said the the friend who died
of pancreatic cancer was saying I'm
detaching oh but I'm sure he was too
only he had two kids it was [ __ ]
terrible
yeah and they were really small you know
it was [ __ ] terrible but sorry so
your friend I was a mutual friend of the
guy with pancreatic cancer was saying
yes catching from that guy yeah he sees
felt guilty because he didn't want to
deal with the pain he didn't know how to
deal with it right yeah it's called
being human man I get that [ __ ] when my
dog got cancer my wife got really mad at
me because I've started to detach I was
like what I was gonna die and I stopped
petting the dog good I can see you're
not betting the dog you're a [ __ ]
scumbag it's the way I protect myself
she's got to go to the great beyond I'll
rescue another dog that's in jail it's
all good I didn't have bought pure
breeds because mutts are for the poor
but here's the thing like you know
saying so so yeah we're we're all human
we're human man right I think that was
one of the things people have trouble
living down is when they've been in and
I've never been in this but they've been
in terrifying situations and they act
they behave in a cowardly manner this is
a they back down the cour and i always
try I think that's the wrong way to
treat yourself my buddy was with his
girlfriend these guys were making noise
downstairs he comes down he's a
beautiful one
human being who helps children and the
dude goes [ __ ] you bro
you got something to say I'll kick your
[ __ ] ass I'll make as much noise as I
want and this girl was watching from the
window and he goes Brian I was terrified
this guy was big and tough and he was I
didn't know what to do so I went back
upstairs and he was so blown away I go
that's called being intelligent yeah if
I read and shop and I don't know him
it's in my face and he's gonna kick my
ass because I went down and told him to
take it down not I'm gonna go all right
go back upstairs I'm sitting my girl
don't you say a [ __ ] word to me if
that guy's a killer and I don't care
I'll eat a dick I'll get a dick so I
don't lose my teeth and have my nose
stopped in or worse right cuz it's
called being intelligent yeah pick your
battles I might get you later I get you
later I might get my window go now the
doors lock you [ __ ] to shoot you in my
pellet gun you're lucky you dick
maybe a little a little a little
well-placed dog poo something like that
like there I got around human poke I'll
show my hand and throw it out of my mind
from the wind out that'll be really
attractive my girl I couldn't fight him
but watch this yeah God sorry hi my hero
good throwing your [ __ ] at somebody from
a window that's a good way to get back
at somebody that might be the only I had
hepatitis you fought from cuz I was a
world class River did you ever get in a
fight uh yeah I'm I was only in like a
couple of fights as a kid and you're a
big guy uh I beat you up there you can't
fight I think I have something in me
that people don't know rate which is
yeah like at the very few times I've
ever been inside it's sort of like I'm
okay with dying like I don't care if you
kill me I'm going to make this so
painful for you that you you will be
bummed that's upset that's the only
thing I've got yes
is great let's go nuclear but I never do
well my buddy my buddy who I always tell
the stories the toughest guy in the
world and my other buddy was there and
they were surfing in Malibu he's a tough
[ __ ] been rustling his whole
life and and big he's big and these guys
came up and they went
get the [ __ ] off our wave and my buddy
Bob goes what what and the guy goes you
heard what the [ __ ] I said get off our
wave and my buddy goes huh how long can
you hold your breath bro they're on
boards right now in the water the guy
goes wedding he goes I said how long can
you hold your breath can he's talking
loud like this my buddies in königsberg
because I'm going to jump off my board
I'll grab you by the hair I'll bring us
down to the bottom of the ocean I can oh
my breath for seven minutes I bet you
can't do that and you'll just [ __ ]
die and then I'll come back up and get
you so you guys want to dance or what so
they [ __ ] looked at him and they
paddled right back to shore they got
their buddies and they're waiting for
him and my buddy goes well here goes
nothing and Caan is a tough [ __ ]
stunt man cuz bro this is bad and my
buddy took his unzipped his like wetsuit
he's ridiculously muskers on the cover
of muscle and fitness back in the day he
could do the Iron Cross he sees the [ __ ]
and we call him the human champion so
strong but this is like six dudes really
I mean I don't care who you are they're
all tough too and my buddy goes like
this my buddy goes alright looks like
somebody's going to lose a nose or an
eye let's go and he just he was game to
go and everybody knew that somebody was
going to you were going to beat him up
but you somebody in this group we got a
one in six chance of losing to know
you're gonna be in it you somebody
somewhere in I fast the rest of your
life and another guy's not going to have
a [ __ ] nose all right so as long as
we know that as long as you I'm not
gambling on those odds I'm not going to
but that dudes going to bite he's going
to be a face biter and an eye gouge er
and he's big and he's a [ __ ] chimp I
don't want to [ __ ] with that guy a guy
in the group recognized him because he
used to wrestle with Rico chipper Ellie
over like I guess like he's to train
with him periodically because you
wrestle with Rico he goes sure did
since no seven because I is cool and
then they end up in I yes chimpanzee
politician we're all [ __ ] Apes huh
whoo-hoo-hoo is alpha alpha my buddy was
like ready to go he's a [ __ ] name
he's he's that guy who when they see a
great white shark shark sighting he goes
and surfs on purpose he's that guy
you're [ __ ] that I'm not not know you
- you're tube beautiful hmm
yeah there's too much to damage mm-hmm
and I'm also I'm also cow it's cow
delicate coward and I'll admit it I get
the only thing I'll do is I'll fight a
bully
[ __ ] with my friend he [ __ ] somebody I
get I get so angry I thought I'd found
that in ninety ninety percent of the
time you can joke your way out of
something I can thank God first of all
it's 50 now so they're not really did
not gonna really try to beat me up right
there was some jiu-jitsu guy I don't
know who he was he was calling me out or
something on a Instagram some weird
video and he thought I was he'd seen
some thing about me and you had this
wrong impression of me I think he would
thought I was being serious or something
I don't I don't remember I don't follow
these things I didn't see it I wouldn't
look at this okay but um he found that I
was 50 and posted another video saying
hey this clarity looks like he's 40 I
don't know he's an old man oh it's got a
deal and I am an old man guys like tough
guys aren't gonna beat me up because I'm
an old man it would be embarrassing at
50 you know what you're gonna do
this is those kind of [ __ ] moments
where well I'm with my feature Stevie
blue eyes just 31 and this woman goes
father son this does I [ __ ] I
get down getting you old eyes I saw
strange though don't like oh I don't
know we worked in the business where
you're sometimes paired you're working
all day with somebody who's 21 years old
or whatever you know or even 18 whatever
it is there is a there was a guy was
working with names 30 and you know 30 is
like an adult and I think of myself as
like you know we were the same were you
know the same level everything and then
he said something like oh I can't we're
we're all going to go out for drinks or
something
he's like I can't make my dad's 51st
birthday and I was like I'm 52 ha ha ha
I thought we were like I'm ill
contemporaries I know like I had a girl
give me business um I'm only saying this
because it was in my wife's hometown and
but I was it was so readily apparent
that I was talking to the guy she was
with but she was I guess not with him
and he was sort of in a weird way
offering her up in a way like she liked
me and I was like I go how's your mother
she goes 46 all right yeah so so just so
you know I'm four years older than your
mom and I have a huge heart on right now
but I'm not going to do it now it was
it's interesting getting older is
interesting I I had a good run though
did you
yeah Michael why are you looking at me
like that
don't you ever like Sarah that's my
that's my my Andy Dick impression is he
would say I got a something
no not a groan no but he would be like
oh my god you're so talented don't you
wish you had gone further and you're not
making a joke and it's like the worst
thing you can say to somebody because I
mean frankly I'm thrilled I never
thought I can remember everything off
working Mike I can remember thinking if
I could just be an extra or actually the
one thing I remember was a the warm-up
person for a sitcom you know they have
yeah in concept during the day hundred
dollars yeah it was
I remember that I one of my one of my
meeting temporaries then he was older
he's like I don't know 30 and I was 20
or something but like he was that and
you know he got to tell jokes yeah and
you know got to be involved he wasn't on
the show but yeah my buddy trying to get
me that yet yeah when I was out of work
my buddy tried to get me that job and I
remember thinking that would be my dream
job you know I'd never so I'd never
thought I would be a warm-up guy yeah
yeah for sure it was like $1500 to the
week or something I don't remember but
it was a lot I was like
yeah so I've yeah I'm grateful for every
I'm grateful for this podcast adorable
they're adorable
but you know it's the right attitude
you've never stopped working but I get
that too like why do you think you
didn't make it yeah well take it easy
man
you see I'm on the Goldbergs relax man
it's decided [ __ ] another deal I'm doing
alright Wendi mclendon-covey another
groundling oh she's so awesome I got her
I love Wendy she said she's money by the
way if you guys like comedy I don't know
I'm going to be at the comedy zone and
Charlotte North Carolina the 20th of
July 21st of July 22nd of July then I'll
be heading on to Just for Laughs
Montreal where I'll be at Cafe Cleopatra
doing one hour show six of them all
right that's all I have to say but only
come if you love to [ __ ] and laugh but
you can't if you don't like if you want
breaks in the hour like if you want to
be able to catch your breath in the hour
don't come to my show Mike okay good oh
no you know in fact you should be I
should be in good physical health in
order to with withstand I haven't see
like people with my god it's a comedy
cycle oh so you're not just a
world-class Rimmer
no I'm not I'm an organic comedian I ran
after with mmm gaming my friend who's
famous there was a girl who used to like
to do that to him and what was his name
and her name he they well his last name
ends with Cruz now uh and and he was Ted
Cruz he'd been working on Ted Cruz and
the Republican the Republican senator
from Texas Tom likes to be really liked
to be read yeah after church
and he he was getting he had been
working all day and she rimmed him he
was like but I got a she goes no you
don't and she goes mmm gaming and an end
of boner and end of all black and no
boners now you go super mouth I can't
kiss you you did it to other guys it's a
problem for me yeah so don't say gay me
after you actually work my rim
and I won't say it to you but I will
look you in the eye while I'm doing it
means you'll be on your back is what is
going on
why do you your father right your parent
are you have any other you can't die
because you have things to teach your
kids that's what you said right
yeah me and Brennan have a relationship
where Brennan will if I have a point of
view on fighting the Brendan is like oh
ho so guy who you're who you're doing a
fine job replacing where where he is
doing what's more important right now
well he's covering the economy Gregor
Floyd Mayweather fights for um Showtime
oh yes so brendan is fast becoming a
fixture in the MMA scene when I bring up
my point of view on MMA to Brendan on
this podcast he is nothing short of
belittling condescending and borderline
disrespectful that's how you treated me
when I brought up [ __ ] it's probably
born of your expertise it's exactly
right because you don't understand
because you go just in one circle cuz
your ass
no pun intended and but I get emails
people I got like saying things like you
need to stand up to Brendan your
children are going to watch this
and they're going to realize that you
were spineless and you didn't stand up
to him being a bully let me tell you all
something right now that's part of our
dynamic i i'm never bullied roles nobody
bullies me I Know Who I am
he's my little brother and I enjoy that
we like to do this kind of thing so
please thank you for your concern but it
got me thinking what are my kids going
to watch what are they going to say that
I'm ashamed of I've done so many
podcasts and told been so honest and
told such outrageous stories on the
Rogan podcast and stuff like about
orgies and stuff and it would be bad the
thing about podcasts too is you forget
it's very easy to forget that you wanted
to keep watching or listening or
anything like that because you know like
I don't know if you were on The Late
Show or something there's cameras all
around and it's pretty yeah he does
any lies like oh I will be careful yeah
but on a on something like this and
especially we know people really well
you suddenly realize it would like you I
think I killed a man when I was 12
yeah when I was 12 let's go to some
current events guys we have to do that
oh yeah you guys are talking about Ricky
martial arts too and Showtime do you
watch mixed martial arts at home Michael
by the Express I'm going to do it for
the audience so they can see what you
did to me and then I'll translate what
it was
do you but makes much work I did that so
what are you judging Michael yeah I'll
take my [ __ ] and balls back whenever you
want to give them to me let me know when
you're done I don't necessarily watch a
lot of fights uh it it bums me out yeah
it you haven't been you don't have
somebody like me to help you navigate it
I want you to come to my house and make
a warm glass of milk you sit on my lap
we're not going to wear pants and I'm
going to bring you through what's going
on but I will do this
I had whenever I find out there's one
where like somebody's arm breaks or let
like a you know I've seen one where I
think a guy gets kicked right in the
shin Anderson Silva yeah then I can't
stop watching that yeah you're either
one extreme or the other I guess so
bring up what this alright so Ariel
Helwani who's like one of the biggest
reporters for MMA yeah he was supposed
to do that thing with Brendan - it was
supposed to be him Brendan Paulie
Malignaggi up and then uh Ariel and more
not more than all - so he was supposed
to be a part of it and then last minute
he flew there and everything last second
they Showtime told him that Dana why or
the UFC specifically asked that he's not
on the show anymore so he they had a
contentious relationship with him they
just don't like him and they waited to
the last the last minute of that huge
the very first press conference I had
for the fight it's interesting Ariel's I
feel like it's almost good for Ariel
because we're talking about it oh yeah
he's always there and he and he's always
doing his job and he's a good journalist
the best you know
really is he's just sensitive and he's
probably like you know he's I don't know
I think I think maybe asks hard
questions and you know he he he's got
that little twinkle in his eye and it
bothers people sometimes he'll ugly [ __ ]
out a fighter some funny dog ate him she
absolutely you know he's also asking
real questions and hard questions and I
don't I've no I don't know enough but i
I've never seen it be that unfair I
agree
by the way like when I when you do press
you know like if you go to Charlotte or
whatever sometimes they they would have
you you're going to do the country music
station at 6:00 in the morning then at
7:00 it's all talk sports whatever right
and they these were these guys that were
all they did on their sports show is I
get so into the weeds you well let's
remember back in 94 when he was batting
at 7:30 but you know like and they're
just they're going into it they go by
the way do you uh you follow
professional but baseball or whatever I
was definitely sport I didn't follow I
said it doesn't matter to me I promise
you I will be able to stay engaged in
the conversation no matter what I said
they would be they would then like gave
me like national they've maybe be like
well so what do you thinks gonna win
there's gonna be the Red Sox or the
White Sox I'd be like it's going to be
one or the other I'll tell you that much
and like they they didn't even um and I
was completely just [ __ ] definitely
wanted depends it depends on it depends
I think the better team's gonna win
whoever gets the ball over the fence
more yeah well what you would at the end
of the day you look at the score the one
with the bigger number they're taking
home the prize surprise you can that's a
not surprise I think I'm the ribbon you
can really you can really [ __ ] your
way through anything yes you can the
baseball team is gonna take home the
ribbon
ok what's the next one
alright this one this lady no you got
sends for flight groping she licked
another slow she's a she's like a 27
year old woman she's hot she's hot
very pretty good picture I hear - oh
it's gone now there she is what [ __ ]
beautiful yeah she has a 19 year old
girl sitting next to her and then she
would lick her ear
and try to make out with her forced to
drink alcohol and touch the inner her
inner thigh and well I didn't know I
didn't know each other I didn't know
each other i 100% approve and I think
she's delicious and so looks pretty
honest I don't think she should be
persecuted I want to you know what hey
wait where was she flying from into
sometimes I don't you might a minute
yeah that's like his Florida involved
she light up and just very drunk and
that's what I'm thinking if she was like
on some kind of a horny pill now good
example of that can ruin you because now
she's 19 she did he's a sort of it was
2010 yeah so she does some stuff I don't
know what happened here it says pleaded
guilty to assault with the intent to
commit a felony
pretty heavy so she's smile she's doing
most likely I I don't know you know it's
well let's see a picture of the victim
well I think they'll show that either
she's so hot I look at her I know this
is just one hour here is she's probably
got probably oh she's probably used to
getting them for getting a yes I was
gonna say no [ __ ] I'd love to dress up
and let's take in a wig and have her do
that to my crotch um and like my ear I
know what I'm saying it's not cheating
if you dress like a woman when you do it
uh well anyway Bravo and I think that's
a little excessive and give me a [ __ ]
break
next all right this is a very
heartwarming story no pun intended
so a bride-to-be her groom secretly flew
in a guy who took her son's heart after
the son passed away uh his heart and
then uh so he surprised her at the
wedding and they brought a stethoscope
so she could hear the heart beating oh
come on crazies I yeah that makes me
want to cry come on uh Jesus
well that is wait that's it was her son
or son that passed away she doesn't look
very old oh he was when I was like 19
and it was a two years ago and this is
the person that received the heart and
and where what was it was a wedding or
is that her wedding or well I'm not sure
what happened with as far as a wedding
beforehand made by god that's crazy now
I swear to God that should be a poster
or something yeah that's her being
surprised
it came what a good dude he is what a
good guy that groom is man what about
yeah what a perfect thing I think the
groom is awesome ooh that makes me want
to cry that's that's a beautiful story
mm-hmm I'm very sensitive I'm
embarrassed right now I got a little
emotional all right take it off okay
well we'll check this out in China they
have a facial recognition machine for
toilet paper because so many people are
stealing the toilet paper there and you
don't talk about I wanted I have so many
racist Joe they do it no okay come on
Mike I can't if Bobby Lee was here who
is not Chinese I know he is Korean jaybo
he would he would dig me on yeah he
would hear anyway um Bobby I get him
back on miss him
exactly I do genome Bobby and I'm not
going to be he's a he's a funny one
so wait but let's get into it aside I
was going down a Raso wormhole we go
facial recognition because people steal
toilet paper from you think like a
really big investment for I mean okay
let's say people are stealing toilet
paper I mean it's not expensive know how
much toilet paper is being stolen in
order to make that investment payoff I
want to know I think people are poor and
they're like you know and I can save
money let's take the toilet paper it
probably happens the minute they put it
in there bandit [ __ ] Chinese bandit
Li they're like so then so you take a
[ __ ] in public your [ __ ] dirty yeah
you can't wipe yet you've got it you've
got to stand up you have no one to go
and you got a me you can you've got no a
world-class Rimmer guys firm you've got
to walk what it seems like stand up and
walk us to good maybe across the
bathroom and then hope you look like you
that day and then get as much toilet
paper as they allow that's kind of crazy
that is a I mean I already can barely
ever take a [ __ ] I'm just in general
like I don't and sort of don't need to
ya ever but you know I mean you lose
everything you eat yeah I'm I'm so
greedy and I'm
but that could only make going poo in
public that much more anxiety cause yeah
that's weird because now is a [ __ ] bank
you know and yeah there's your digital
your digital memory thing like you might
say that DNA goes no [ __ ] into it -
he's not smiling now I'm not although
they have a picture of in there it gives
you a new suit of toilet paper feet uh
yeah yeah - feeder from toilet paper
every nine minutes with the same thing
the details are what really make holy
[ __ ] every nine minutes but at times two
feet I think I might need more banding
all right all right laughing Jamie
growing hero except poor Joe how about
this in Florida a family was getting
caught up in a Riptide
Chris girl so all the beach goers like
80 plus beachgoers formed a human chain
to save them I hope I saw this Wow I
need this that's bad I saved everyone
so yeah everybody and and one of the
family members was a like the matriarch
of it had a heart attack on the beach
marina in the van we'll be back but they
say they survived here yes you know if
you con Riptide let it take you and swim
along the beach if everybody wants to
know a surfers use it to their advantage
but when you fight it in beer it's in
South of France where I summer sometimes
cuz I come I make a fortune actually my
friend does um just gonna say you'll get
died like twice two three four or five
people a year they just get drunk and
they just don't see just takes you it
should take I've had a a little bit of
an obsession with being lost at sea like
it did you ever see that movie open
water I sure did it's terrifying that
was when that not no no listen if you
want to soar if you want me to cry like
a [ __ ] like a baby
it took this way to talk about you know
human you know well he's brave wouldn't
be brave brave when brave when he knows
how to navigate that situation when he
knows how to run a pump back when he
knows how to deal with the Octagon me
take you drop in the middlee ocean right
before it gets dark
yeah we're gonna take off we'll see you
later it's 20 miles back to shore
try that yeah yeah now horrify Vienna
because you don't know what's under you
right that's why I don't even really
love swimming in lakes oh and it's it's
a real weird thing and I'm a good like
great swimmer you know was a swimming
teacher like I can I can swim forever
you bought improv and swimming huh I did
I taught swimming when I was in high
school with Gwen Stefani man [ __ ] out of
here and you did yeah with Gwen yeah
what was she like awesome she was
awesome she was um like I think I'm
about four years older than her but like
I was I think I was in college it was a
summer job and we taught in Anaheim and
she was this little you know she kind of
had the little Madonna she came weren't
cut she's five seven yeah something like
that don't know but she was um she was
absolutely adorable sweet and kind and
her she like we always gave her all the
kids who cried because she was able to
to completely make them feel better what
a woman and and on top of it then like
we would go out and like get beers
afterwards typically you know and like
go buy a 12-pack and then sit behind you
know the backstop of the high school
where we taught swimming dumb teenage
stuff but we would say to Gwen like do
you want to come with us we're going to
have beers and she's like I'm gonna go
practice with my brother's band we were
like well good luck with that
yeah good luck with that Gwen Stefani
yeah and then there didn't her Gavin
that guy cheated on her I don't know I'm
guessing he didn't has he done anything
besides glitter room hey ray the way
gryzzl room I don't know he has one song
that's right yeah Bush close around what
a good-looking guy hmm but I don't care
all right
whatever dad all right I got one last
one this is making headlines now because
a guy a KKK guy was caught wearing
dreadlocks and it's like all over the
black Twitter
and it's going foul right now uh you got
a little box shut up a KKK rally because
hate doesn't make sense
one race not have the exclusive right to
wear dreadlocks also until I read this
article I did not know there was a black
Twitter that I guess why people are not
welcome you know my thought on that is I
don't like it really when any white
person has dreadlocks that's how I
thought that I always think it's
[ __ ] i I always there appropriating
something no it's not that
I just think oh really did you need
because you know how hard they have to
work to dreadlock their hair you know
like it's only was normally straight
hair and they're there they're doing
everything to it yeah it forever it
feels to me like there's just so much
effort that whenever you see somebody
putting that much effort into something
I just kind of it's an eye roll yeah I
would agree with you there's a lot of a
Kouta mall
so he's a Klansman the way he's wearing
black it's interesting and with the
cross I guess there's different art
there's different uniforms now into the
Klan huh yeah there's now they're more
just Pro white is that the idea we're
not that black GQ really yeah it's like
we just are Pro white all right I wonder
I wonder how big of a deal the Klan is
like is it doesn't even know like how
how prevalent it is so I mean I've never
ever met somebody in the Klan but yeah I
might be related to so but yeah I don't
think frankly that they are going to
take over the world anytime soon
they're kind of where are they where is
that probably some worse I'm pretty
solid down and it could be florida rural
somewhere Charlottesville North Carolina
well that's where I'm Virginia what am I
oh yeah Charlotte I mention saloon
Charlotte Charlotte North Carolina
I don't know I'm looks look there's a
way to work it in are they are they are
they in Charlotte North Carolina are
they near the hominy zone here comedy
show at July 22 21st when I'm doing Stan
because if they are having a freak out I
will I will destroy them with wit and
humor show us the next thing that was
rich amazing slow news day slow news day
on this day I usually have a segment
called dropping knowledge what
percentage of Americans say they've seen
a ghost I'm gonna say 60%
gin octane 90 the answer is 17% oh wow
according to one stat according to a
made-up place that I according to what
goes on in my brain in order to win a
bar bets yes yes and how do you prove
that they haven't seen it have you ever
seen a gun I sure haven't don't believe
in them although the Bible and lots of
different religious Scripture always
gives quarter to ghosts have you ever
lost somebody that you were close to who
has visited to you in a dream no yeah
yeah or I mean that you've dreamt about
them yeah you can characterize either
way yeah but I would call that a dream
but yeah I have you know I mean is there
anybody close to you into our mystery
aren't they yeah have you ever anybody
close to you that you've lost do you
ever talk to them after they passed no
no honestly can't cancer that that's the
case yeah you you I guess you just end
on bad terms with everyone I feel I'm
talking to you and they died ever their
fault for being weak for leaving you but
yeah we you know don't die you know how
about you uh yeah yeah for sure
everybody coast I don't know because I
was so bereaved by one thing in
particular that I don't think I was in
the friend or family member friend oh
man well hold
uh he was 49 hmm this is recently yeah
oh man yeah that sucks
they died he took his life ah that Oh
was it Chris Cornell no no this is my
best friend growing up oh my god yeah
was I yeah that's a debt of who talk a
little bit about that like where people
take their own life and you didn't you
never know it or at least it's just so
incomprehensible you can't figure out
what level of despair they were going
through you know yeah it's the worst
thing in the world
yeah did you see it coming did he have a
history of eyes both with him four days
before uh and I can't believe I'm
talking about this it's all right you
don't have to but you know I think it
helps other people right the reason I
think it's important to talk about stuff
like this sometimes a lot of people are
listening and I get emails people there
are allowed to us feel this way that
feel like they maybe want to right right
I think it helps them navigate you
especially cuz you and I are older and
we've lived a life right maybe maybe
maybe you can give him some perspective
you know and sometimes there are no
answers but I don't know I always feel
like there's something to be gained yeah
uh well first of all it's the worst yeah
it's the worst yeah I found you found
him and I did not see it coming I've
spoken with him days before we we were
activists was the Oscars really and I
was throwing an Oscar party and he you
know I did every year it was small small
group and you know pizza and talk shed
and you know root and cheer for people
and uh like I said I'd known him forever
and he lived down the street and people
started coming to the party and I just I
texted him a couple of times like you
know
just like I haven't heard from you you
know are you definitely coming or not
you know he would normally been there
like an hour early
yeah and uh I I could have walked to the
house but I just drove because I was
worried and found yeah it's a worst
thing in the world man yeah that's the
craziest thing in the world that kind of
stuff yeah and what it does is it makes
you the people that you leave behind it
it makes them question doubt like
whether you know you life or what they
could have done what they differently
could have done out it's only they had
seen it makes you you replay the tape um
like we went we went hiking in Runyon
Canyon because I live right near there
and we we would hike all the time that
was among to me we traveled the world
together we every Christmas we cook you
know together and noonim since I was 14
he's really like my brother and um how
long ago is it Mike asked two years ago
days ago um but it makes you um replay
everything in your mind you know like
what oh did he
when when he said this did that mean
this you know you you uh but he'll make
yourself crazy that way right because
because because even if you know
somebody I feel like we don't know
anybody but ourselves I really feel that
way like I didn't I thank me I didn't I
thought I thought uh I thought I knew
you know there was that was I guess I'll
call it a lesson from it was you don't
know what you think you know
and that's what you mean by question
everything right yeah you know and blame
myself for I mean I still do to a degree
but like you question whether you're any
good as a friend if you are it it it
affects the people around you so
indelibly and and the aftermath of it is
is horrific yeah you know there's
there's a lot of the logistics to death
in general but for something like that
it's it's even worse you know and having
to tell the family you had to well I
didn't want the police to oh you know
that's the choice my god so how do you
do that how the [ __ ] do you do that I've
always wanted about that like doctors
have come out I you know it's I mean
you're not prepared for that there's no
perpare of no no the script for that you
know no I actually actually called I had
to get on his phone - I know I know his
family from childhood I didn't have
their numbers so the only way I could
get their number was from his phone and
I didn't want to call the parents
because I felt like they need a buffer
yeah I felt I felt like they deserve to
hear about it from one of their own
Lamech I just it was like a respect
thing that makes total sense so I called
his brother and I wasn't thinking I mean
I didn't chop your yeah and it was blur
and so I called his brother from his
phone and his brother said hey man
thinking it was my friend I don't want
to say his name but yeah um and I said
oh it's it's not him
it's Mike and this is a guy I've known
my whole life but I don't talk to him ya
know and I could hear I said it sounds
like you're in the car and he said yeah
I am
what's going on and I said well I have
to you know tell you something but I
think you should pull up and he said
well I'm on the 405 right down by Camp
Pendleton and there's no off ramps there
like every three or four miles so he
said it's three miles to the off-ramp um
I said that's okay I'll just ride with
you until you can pull over and he knew
it at this point something was up well
he you know he said I'm getting nervous
and I said well you know we don't have
to talk you know just just when you get
to a spot to pull over pull over and and
that three miles is about three minutes
yeah it's about three years and it ended
yeah it I mean so I I told him and um it
to to have that knowledge that what
you're about to say to somebody is going
to break their heart yeah this is the
hardest thing yeah it's amazing that two
years later it's so hard for you to talk
about - yeah it's uh sorry kisses I
appreciate it man I can't believe you
think you're gonna come on the fight on
kit and talk about this no I didn't
didn't well I did we shared it man I
mean I think it's really important out
because it helps people you know yeah do
with that grief I lost two years I'd say
in Mitton some respects loss to you yeah
I just uh it like it messes with you
messes with your
it mess with my confidence is really
yeah I would say that what do you mean
like I just I didn't think I what I knew
I feel like I didn't know what was real
you know what if I if I didn't see that
if I couldn't see that coming
then I don't you know my eyes have not
open like so it makes you question
lots of things and it's a terrible he
can I my only hope and wish is that he
knows how loved he will was yeah I don't
know what it's like obviously to be in
that mindset none of us do until we do
it but I think that that level of
despair or that sort of decision that
there's no way out of this and this is
the best in the easiest way I don't
think has anything to do with anybody
but themselves and that and that's
totally me sorry you know that's another
thing like I I think you also then feel
like well wait this isn't about you
you're you know it's it is though isn't
it I mean it's you can say that the
problem with this is that you can
intellectualize but sometimes like I'm
Hickson Gracie was talking about when he
lost his son and he's a warrior he's oh
he's a one of the great jujitsu fighter
MMA fighters you know pioneer in and
he's a God among the MMA community
introduced community and and he was a
yogi and all that stuff and and he said
he finally had to realize that he hit
rock bottom
like he realized that sometimes there's
no answer and there's no way out of the
grief and it just brought him to his
[ __ ] me and there are things in life
like this that did this to you that
bring you to your knees yeah and and and
I and I think that sometimes all you can
do as I get older
there's no answer there's nothing I can
say there's nothing a priest can say or
anybody else sometimes you just got to
feel bad you got to surrender to it yeah
you got to realize that there are no
answer
and that you did lose confidence and
that you are changed from it and
ultimately it's okay because you know
we're made of flesh and blood man
we're so vulnerable aren't we we're so
other the other thing is so hard as when
you have children are you just a human
being you you build this life for
yourself and you guys can be taken away
this quickly right
we're flesh and blood and and so not
only but emotionally we're so fragile
you look at this like you know your your
your brother for all intents purposes
well how did this
so we there and then life turns things
around in the weird way so we cooked
Thanksgiving dinner together every year
and the Ferguson riots happened later
that year's like around November and I
was I had spent by that point about six
months just bawling my eyes out and I'm
bursting into tears at dry cleaners at
you name it like all I was not in
control at all like I couldn't I just
had crying jacks and so I was driving to
the store to buy the Thanksgiving turkey
and this was the first Thanksgiving I
was going to be cooking on my own and I
remember being so depressed and so I
turn on talk radio and all talk when
you're depressed what do you do talk
radio but I just needed something to get
my mind off of it it was all this [ __ ]
about the Ferguson riots and and racial
unrest and racial unrest really it
really bums me out more even yeah so I
go into the line at the supermarket and
I'd already ordered my turkey it was
like one of those frou-frou things were
talking about okay
yeah sure raised and there was a woman
right in front of me and she's a little
black very old black lady and she was
ordering her turkey and it was so big
that like it was as big as her belly
like the guy had to carry it out and put
it put it in her cart and she goes you
know thank you very much she goes around
to the check that's my old black lady
boy very good well you're going to hear
more of it so I get up to the next and
the guy says you know but what what
I get for you I'm like a turkey and he
says okay for how many people and I go
ten and then I remembered my friend was
not going to be there I go I mean nine
and we got and just right there right
there and that's it happened all the
time and that was it just the one idea
that I'm not couldn't pretend there's
one less person at the table and so he
gave me I mean literally walked the
turkey out just like a typical black
lady because I was so upset that I I
become my hands were shaking I get in
line right behind the little black lady
and she's pushing her she pushes out
like right in front of me and the
parking lot it's the whole to the
Bristol Farms on Sunset after fact it's
got like a slight little thing to it so
she's pushing and I can see her fighting
to keep the cart you know going and I
was in my grief and I was thinking like
maybe I can turn this into a positive
what could I do what I do I can help
this little black lady with her bidding
turkey so I I get to the she got to her
car and I I was like she can't lift it
out and put it in the car so I I caught
up to her and I said excuse me ma'am
would you like some help with your
turkey and she said oh no that's all
right yeah and I had taken my hand off
and I said no really I'd like to help
and in that moment in it's almost like
in slow motion my cart just starts to
drift and it and it's got a big heavy
turkey and bunches of tons of wine like
it's heavy
it's like I can have a edit [ __ ]
eclipse her cards all [ __ ] and her cart
then just pushes it's not it's not
whizzing but it just pushes in the
corner of the metal cart just grazes her
car door and she puts like a good
14-inch scratch in her car and I
literally I look at her and I and I just
burst into tears I help my friend I love
I'm just volunteering and blubbering all
this advert
and my friend died and she and she was
so sweet she she put her hand on my
shoulder and she said sweetheart things
is just things now you have a good
Thanksgiving and don't you worry about
it
another phone call text are you sure
thank you and I go push my like
Thanksgiving turkey over to my car still
crying and I'm thinking you know like my
heart is sort of warm with human spirit
and you know this woman who had the
graces saying things is just things and
then as I you know getting into my car I
hear her I didn't see there was a old
black man in the passenger seat waiting
for her she go did you see what I bought
in my car ah oh [ __ ] and oh my god oh my
god that's that weirdly that horrible
horrible event led to so many crazy
experiences and I guess it's just you
sort of realized the fullness of this is
one of my favorite podcasts I've ever
done I'm not kidding that was a really
amazing story thanks for sharing that
because I think that helped people
because I'm sure there are a lot of
people who are going through what you're
going through they don't know how to put
it in the context talk to somebody and
also if you if you suspect somebody of
being in that place don't be afraid or
embarrassed to bring up the subject talk
to them well dude thanks man I think
those are very important words this has
been a [ __ ] clod cast we won't be
sorry
are you kidding we went from [ __ ] to
one of them more if one or more powerful
kind of stories and I think that's what
I love about doing [ __ ] like this that's
why I do want to plan anything with you
not cuz I thought you'd tell the story
but because you know it's just great to
kind of discover this stuff yeah nothing
you're good you're good too
you're much better
host than I thought you would be well I
appreciate that guy on that is the thing
I'd you think you have to be on all the
time this is if I run into you in a like
a what a great time yeah and you're just
on on on and always makes me laugh yeah
it's always fun but man then you get
into what counts and what matters and
and that's a that's an amazing powerful
story so goddamn that's a it's one of my
favorite podcasts Mike McDonald thank
you thanks for having expectations to be
in this it always helps it always helps
now you're always a killer I've always
been an admirer I've always been a fan
and it doesn't surprise me and I'm I'm
so sorry about your grief but I'm really
glad you shared it because I think it's
going to help people through it I hope
it does it does it's the only reason to
talk about it yeah yeah you know and it
means something and you're suffering
matters ladies and gentlemen um I
appreciate you guys listening
I've already plugged my dates not going
to do it again but God bless you Mike
McDonald you are welcome back any
[ __ ] time and this has been the fight
or the kid we're out